the love and support you guys have shown
for the film is so exciting honestly
that is just the tip of the iceberg you
have no idea what else is to come i'm so
excited to share more with you guys and
uh
it feels so good it feels so good to be
back with spider-man to be showing you
trailers to be having films coming out
this is so exciting so uh so yeah i love
you all thank you for your support and
uh and enjoy the trailer
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday after waiting for such a long
time we finally got the spider-man no
way home teaser trailer and it was worth
every second of the wait and it did not
disappoint at all and i said it
yesterday but i'll say it again i'm
actually shocked with how much they
actually revealed in this teaser trailer
they literally revealed the spider-verse
they revealed that the spider-verse is
going to be basically the main story of
spider-man no way home and i think we're
all starting to realize now that the no
way home title isn't necessarily
referring to peter parker well at least
not r peter parker it is referring to
the other two peter parkers that are
going to be joining soon and the
villains that are coming from different
universes as well they literally
revealed the spider-verse and now tom
holland as you saw is teasing even more
that is just the tip of the iceberg you
have no idea what else is to come i'm so
excited to share more with you guys
it's very curious and exciting that tom
holland says honestly that's just the
tip of the iceberg and you have no idea
what else is to come and this is pretty
funny because while the general public
may not have any idea of what's to come
we definitely know what's coming the
spider-verse specifically two other
spider-man who were missing in the
trailer or were they no we didn't see
them but there are definitely signs of
them being there i think specifically in
this scene right here where we have
alfred molina where he makes his debut
in the mcu as doc ock here from the sam
raimi universe he gives us that classic
iconic line hello peter and i think most
people have realized that he's not
actually talking to our peter parker
this is a classic misdirect from marvel
they do this all the time with their
trailers now after he says hello peter
it shows our peter parker not in his
suit however after he immediately puts
on his iron spider suit via nanotech so
the trailer is making us believe that
doc ock is talking to our peter parker
of the mcu there's only one problem with
that doc ock doesn't know our peter
parker if he saw our peter parker just
in normal clothes he would have no idea
that he's spider-man he's from the sam
raimi universe his peter parker is toby
maguire and he knows that at the end of
spider-man 2 peter parker's identity was
revealed to him and this actually made
him become good at the end but looking
at r peter parker tom holland he would
have no idea that he's spider-man if he
wasn't in his suit and the way he says
hello peter with that smile on his face
definitely screams toby maguire he's
more than likely looking at tobey
maguire's peter parker because he is now
in the mcu as well now if you've been
following my channel i've actually
talked a lot about many accurate leaks
that were confirmed to be true in this
teaser trailer so i know some people may
be thinking well they weren't in the
trailer and doc ock isn't necessarily
talking to another spider-man but the
people that have told me about the leaks
being true that were confirmed true in
the last trailer are the same people
telling me that toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man are
indeed going to be in the film and the
film confirmed the spider-verse it took
characters from other universes the sam
raimi universe and the mark webb amazing
spider-man universe and brought them
into our own the spider-verse is
confirmed so with both of these things
happening there's no reason to believe
that toby mcguire and andrew garfield
aren't going to be in the film to me
it's pretty evident at this point which
leads me to believe that yes alfred
molina's dog ock right here is talking
to toby not tom holland now i have been
told that yes toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man will
indeed be in a trailer before the movie
comes out i know a lot of people are
wondering about this and already asking
me about this i've stated it before and
now i'll state it again they're going to
be in a trailer right before the movie
comes out an actual trailer not like a
short little tv spot but an actual final
trailer of course this could change but
this is what i've been told by the same
people telling me about all of these
very accurate leaks and if you think
about it it just makes sense the next
trailer they're going to tease the
spider verse even more show us more of
the villains probably reveal jaime fox's
electro and willem dafoe's green goblin
maybe briefly tease that spider-man is
going to need help and that other
spider-man might be coming and then in
the final trailer give us just a tiny
tiny little glimpse of the other two
spider-men this makes sense because it's
going to build up this teaser they
teased the multiverse or spider-verse
and they briefly teased all of the
villains revealing only really alfred
molina but we did get glimpses of the
other villains and in case you missed it
i'll explain we got lightning from jamie
foxx's electro we also got the sandman
pretty much combined with the lightning
each time we have a scene where
something pops up behind peter and grabs
at him and we believe that to be the
lizard of course we got alfred molina
actually revealed and then there's the
green goblins pumpkin bomb and not only
the pumpkin bomb but that iconic willem
dafoe green goblin laugh
those are the villains for now with
lizard kind of being a question mark but
pretty much confirmed to be him so the
next official trailer should actually
reveal them and reveal the plot these
villains coming from other universes
other dimensions doctor strange
mentioned the multiverse in this teaser
trailer and the next teaser is going to
be about these villains coming from
their universes into ours and fighting
peter parker and then in the final one
we will probably learn that the villains
weren't the only people to come over
from their universes but some heroes
came as well and it's pretty much going
to be three spider-men versus the
sinister six now we don't know who the
sixth member of the sinister six is yet
but we pretty much have narrowed it down
like i mentioned right now we have doc
ock green goblin electro sandman and the
lizard most likely our other options are
a few actually there's a really good
chance that mysterio could be alive
after all he is the master of illusions
if anyone could fake their death
extremely well it would be mysterio and
i actually really hope this is the case
because i think jake gyllenhaal did an
amazing job and i think mysterio is such
a cool villain i don't want him to be
gone i'd really like him to return but
at the same time michael keaton's
vulture has been revealed of course in
spider-man homecoming now we didn't see
him at all in spider-man far from home
but we did see him in the morbius
trailer implying that he is kind of
around right now also not to mention
scorpion is also in the mcu right now as
well and as of right now there isn't
really a villain from the mcu all of
these other villains are from either the
sam raimi universe or the amazing
spider-man universe so to have vulture
or scorpion or mysterio as the sixth
member of the sinister six makes sense
because it's a villain from tom's
present universe but then again it is
going to be a spider-verse multiverse
film so maybe that's just not the way
they're going maybe it's just all about
villains from other universes but of
course like i mentioned at the top of it
all is going to be the big three tom
hall and spider-man toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man and i absolutely cannot wait
until we see them in a trailer and on
screen and this is what tom holland is
referring to when he says that this is
just the tip of the iceberg these
classic iconic villains coming in this
teaser trailer the tip of the iceberg
that can only mean one the other
spider-man are coming and two we have
absolutely no idea how incredible some
of the scenes where everybody is
interacting are going to be and i really
think this movie has the potential to be
one of the greatest movies of all time
but those are just my thoughts let me
know yours in the comments down below
and if you're new to the channel and
want to stay up to date on spider-man
and the mcu please consider subscribing
and click that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you